I invite you to join the discussion on the
David Pakman show.
Read it at David Pakman dot com slash our
a._d._d I-T.
More than 19000 of you have already done that.
A few interesting posts I spotted.
One is about the suicide rate that Donald
Trump has been talking about lately, asking
why does no one ever question Trump on the
high suicide rate, falling life expectancy
and rising opioid usage before Cauvin 19 whenever
he brings them up as a reason to reopen the
country?
Yeah, this is a very fair question.
We are being Gaslight Daily by Donald Trump.
When Donald Trump pulls out a piece of paper
from his suit jacket with a graph of the just
number of tests that the United States has
done, we are being gasoline, right?
We are a country of three hundred and thirty
one million people.
And what matters is the per capita testing
rate.
When Donald Trump now says, listen, staying
home can make people depressed, people could
commit suicide, people are addicted to drugs.
These are things Donald Trump has not indicated
he ever cared about before, and they were
problems before.
So you're completely right to point out the
cynical nature of that.
And I wish Donald Trump were asked about it.
But, you know, he would just lie and move
on to the next question.
Another user says reminds us that Justice
Ruth Bader Ginsburg is in the hospital with
an infection, which is not good news.
And I want to just take this as an opportunity
to remind everybody that we want Justice Ruth
Bader Ginsburg to recover and we wish her
the best and we want her to stay on the court.
She says she wants to be honored until she's
90 and we want her to be able to do that.
And that's absolutely fantastic.
And we love her.
And it reminds us of the fact that there is
an a level of dread that we experience when
we hear that she's in the hospital and we
know that Donald Trump is president and gets
to pick Supreme Court justices.
Just a reminder about the importance of who
is allowed to select the next Supreme Court
justice.
Very, very important.
Lastly, a post on our subreddit from user
John Ex Wall, who says, how can you prove
you are not a sexual assaulter?
I don't know the answer to this.
I think that this is something that needs
to be discussed.
And you all know my positions on on allegations
of sexual assault.
I believe that as a general rule, these need
to be taken seriously.
They need to be investigated.
We need to ensure that men or women who are
victims of sexual assault are not dissuaded
from coming forward because of how they expect
to be treated or shame or whatever else.
I don't know how you prove that you didn't
sexually assault someone when there is not
a criminal proceeding.
I think that many of us, if there is actually
a criminal trial about rape, for example,
and the individual is found not guilty, of
course, we all know you can be found not guilty
and have actually done the thing you were
accused of, but legally be not guilty.
But I believe that there is more of a sense
that when you're found not guilty of rape,
you didn't do it, even though, of course,
that that's not always the case when you have
an allegation that never gets to a police
report or a criminal proceeding and the accused
perpetrator denies it.
I don't know how you prove you didn't do it.
I really don't.
And I don't even have anything to add.
I would leave it to you to give me some thoughts
about that.
Join these discussions at David Pakman dot
com slash.
Read it.